crackling flames on an active day for  the kaldor fire tearing through trees  and rising over ridges near the gray  rock campground off silver fork road  that fire is breathing today and it's  getting moved along with that wind  activity often on wind throughout a red  flag warning day fanning the flames  sending spots across highway 50 a small  blaze burning on the hillside surrounded  by smoky orange skies this was one of  the control points so it does raise some  concern concern as it burns only miles  away from the evacuated tiny town of  kuipers much of these areas of the  eldorado national forest haven't seen  fire in decades the fuels are thick  they're primed to burn crews  strategically scattered around the area  ready for what could come they're in for  a firefight today but they're doing the  best they can air quality making air  attacks near impossible making for a  tough fire fight amid rugged steep  terrain